welcome back we hope you had a great
break
and we're able to refresh we're really
looking forward to
at the afternoon session we've got some
great stuff lined up first
a fireside chat with sudamay and then
we'll have our poster session which will
give us more
opportunities to interact with each
other um and engage and then
following that at the end of the day we
have a networking session
so really uh looking forward to lots of
chances to have
conversations and meet new people and
discuss research so to start with
we're delighted to have sudamay here
with us
she is currently the
managing um director of microsoft
research labs
in new england new york and montreal so
she has a unique position
spanning three different labs which
makes her a very busy person
traveling to and and from she's
one of the most highly cited researchers
uh in msr and has received
uh lifetime achievement awards from sid
kai
and sig ir and her her research is
really a fantastic example of
interdisciplinary
research and so look forward to
discussing that more as we get into our
conversation
she's also a member of the kai academy
sigar academy
national academy of engineering and the
american academy
of arts and sciences and an acm fellow
so really just a amazing body of work
that she's contributed so welcome to
susan
thanks daniel it's a pleasure to be here
and welcome to
all the the visitors from many different
uh universities in the us
and and beyond i believe absolutely
uh so to start off with could you uh
tell us a little
about yourself and about your journey to
msr and in research as a whole
sure yeah it's interesting when i was
growing up i aspired to
to do lots of different things but i can
certainly assure you that
being a technical fellow at microsoft or
the director of
three microsoft research labs was not
among them
so i grew up in maine in an industrial
mill town i was the first in my family
to
to go to college i went to a small
liberal arts school bates college which
turned out to be only a few doors
away from where i grew up when i went to
college i had the intention of going to
law school to study environmental law
and so i majored in math because i was
pretty good at it and it also allowed me
to the opportunity since it didn't have
all that many requirements to
take lots of of other courses and
there was a moment when i was a junior i
took a course
in mathematical psychology now would be
called cognitive science
and i was just fascinated by the
possibilities of understanding
human intellect by being able to
quantitatively model things like human
memory learning perception
and so i i just ditched the plans to go
to law school and decided
to take grades and go to graduate school
in cognitive science
and you know while i was in graduate
school there i did a lot of work in
human memory and perception also work in
visual motor development in young
infants
and i was all set to be a professor at a
university that's what i thought i would
do
after graduate school but alas i had
another change in plan so just as i was
going on the
the job market bell labs was starting
a the very first human computer
interaction
group in industry tom landauer was
starting that and hired a handful of
people
and in the end i just decided it was a
tremendous opportunity to be at the
beginning of something completely
different
uh work with an amazing set of
colleagues in in different areas and i
thought figured if i didn't like it
i could leave in a few years it's been
uh almost 40 years since that time now
so i guess i can say that i liked uh
the industrial research lifestyle and
environment
when i was at bell labs one of the
things i worked on was a system
a very early word embedding system
called latent semantic indexing
which to this day still accounts for a
huge proportion of my
my citations and for those of you who
are familiar with today's deep learning
models
this was about as polar opposite as you
can get it was a very simple linear
factorization model
train on tiny amounts of data with very
little compute
and a few hundred parameters but even
with these limitations the model was
able to successfully
improve information retrieval we
actually tried something
having to do with human parity we had it
we had the system
take the test of english as a foreign
language and it did as well as the
average test taker
and so there was some real promise in in
this method
um and because finally 23 years ago i
joined
microsoft research where i've been since
and at microsoft i've worked on
lots of different projects that daniel
alluded to at the intersection of human
computer interaction information
retrieval and and ai
i thought i'd just mention uh you know a
few of the things that i've really
enjoyed uh doing it at microsoft and and
then um
uh and then reflect on sort of what i'm
currently doing
the very first project i actually worked
on was with an an intern my first uh
intern at microsoft a guy named
sahami who's now
on the faculty at stanford along with
david heckerman and eric corvitz we
worked on what was probably the first
email spam filter
this was back in 1997
and the system spun out to be actually a
product that was offered in outlook
online and i think it's been operational
for almost 20 years it's probably one of
the longest living
ai systems if if you will um a couple of
other things i've worked on that i
really enjoyed again are at the
intersection of people
and algorithms the first is a system
called stuff i've seen
which created quite literally a unified
index
to help people find any information
they'd seen
regardless of where they had seen it
whether it was an email
on the web in a document and you know at
that time
the gateway that people had to most
information
was really from a single desktop machine
so our task was quite easy from a
an infrastructure point of view and we
concentrated a lot on user experience
and
interfaces today this task
i think has become much more complicated
with a proliferation of devices that we
all own
a ton of web services but it's still the
capability that i really need and and
miss
on a day-to-day basis and then finally
let me just
talk a little bit about a lot of work
that i've done with many folks at
microsoft and
in several different product groups on
context and personalization
in search and again the idea is really
quite simple
and it's simply that one size doesn't
fit all
in web search um and by that what i mean
is that what's relevant
to the same query will vary depending on
who's asking
it you know what they've done in the
immediate past
what their longer term interests and
preferences are
it'll vary depending on when they ask it
where they are and and so on and
representing this kind of contextual
metadata makes it
much easier to do this challenging task
of taking 2.3 words and making any sense
of it so in answering people's really
short web queries and so
that spans some of the the things i've
i've done it at microsoft from
algorithms to
search related applications and
experiences and i now spend this as
daniel said most of my time
doing much less research on my own and
more time on
technical leadership and lan lab
management which i really like in
in very very different ways
great thank you for that overview and uh
previous to your current role you were
the assistant director of msrai
um and just thinking at a high level
given your
um you know fantastic experience over
the past
20 30 years kind of looking at ai
problems
what do you think are the really key
accomplishments that you've seen
and the biggest challenges or
opportunities moving forward
yeah um that's a really broad question
and i i guess i could answer it
in lots of ways let me focus on
um what i'll call the first decade of
the the deep learning
revolution uh and so yeah i think it's
amazing for
uh people who've been in graduate school
throughout the the deep learning uh
decade to realize that we're only uh you
know really eight or nine years
into using deep learning techniques at a
scale and uh and
applications that have become really
really commonplace so there are a ton of
amazing accomplishments
some huge challenges and msr is really
trying to
bridge the gap between aspirations and
and experiences
let me just talk you know a little bit
about the course of progress in
in speech recognition and maybe language
understanding
so if for if you plot example for
example something like word error rate
in speech recognition systems things
like the switchboard collection from
from nist what you see is a lot of
progress from 1990 to about 2000
and then a huge plateau for about a
decade
and then all of a sudden in about 2009
2009 i guess it was george dahl jeff
hinton and
spent the summer at msr and
doing work on deep acoustic modeling for
automatic speech recognition
i couldn't imagine that they could make
any progress given
really the decades that folks at bell
labs and other places had spent
fine-tuning features for speech
recognition
but you know they they definitely proved
me wrong and
what really changed during that time
and over the next three years was just
that there was a lot more training data
there were really much richer and deep
models
and a lot more compute and so you saw
progress again from
2009 to maybe 2015 take a
um you know a huge
just huge advantages in progress in in
that area
and also you know in language
representation
uh i alluded to early some of the work
that i had done back in the 1990s on
language modeling um and
that was based on a very very small
amount of data
uh yesterday benjio picked up some of
those ideas around 2003 i guess it was
uh
building a feed forward net neural
language model
and he used probably two orders of
magnitude more data
uh three orders of magnitude more
parameters in in this model and showed
some progress
but it still wasn't um you know showing
that
the kinds of progress and robustness
that that one would like to deploy it
at scale and so uh you know it was
another decade
before 2013 when word to vec
became more popular and again there was
a two order of magnitude increase and
the number of words and the number of
model parameters
um and there were some really
interesting applications of that but a
lot of the progress has happened really
just in the last two or three years
where we've gone against several orders
of magnitude not
now not decade after decade but almost
year after year
and so i i think this um
these new models that are based on
using a ton of data really rich
transformer style models with a
attention um they've been just
tremendous accomplishments
that are enabled by this so you know you
pick up this this phone
i can talk to it and the speech is
recognized we see
image captioning natural language
understanding and generation
machine translation even things going
from
real time translation from one language
to another that is powered by many of
these capabilities and i think these are
just amazing things that that we take
for granted um you know as a community
we should be really proud of that
but the systems also have a ton of
limitations
and these are starting to to surface you
know they can be biased
they can be very fragile subject to
adversarial noise where
changes that are completely invisible to
to humans
dramatically change the recognition
class of items
these systems in many ways have really
say narrow web
wedges of competency they're very good
at a small task
often driven by available test
collections
you know in many senses they're they're
doing a really good job of
memorizing a lot of patterns and those
get you a long way
but i think what we're you know lacking
uh here is
really the ability to to generalize in
a variety of interesting new directions
so
some of the work that we're doing at
msrai i think lays the foundation for a
variety of new approaches to
address these limitations and i hope
that you've had
some opportunities to you know hear
about some of the work on theoretical
foundations
that underlie these empirical successes
i think all of the models need to be
much more robust
to changes in distribution into unknown
unknowns
i think increasingly people are
developing not these wedges
of expertise but more universal
models and universal representation
across different tasks
across generation and understanding
across different modalities
and i think increasingly we're seeing
models
that don't live in a test collection
but are grounded in the real world and
leverage
some higher level representations based
on
prior knowledge look at entities and and
different levels of abstraction so i
think those are really
important new directions and we're doing
a lot of that in
you know at microsoft and in microsoft
ai
i'd be uh you know a little bit remiss
not to to mention that above and beyond
these
challenges in and progress in
capabilities
i think we as a community also just need
to do a much better job of
thinking about learning with better
sample efficiency
and thinking about building models that
can be
served at a cost that's just not
prohibitively
expensive so i think uh you know as i
outlined it at the beginning
there's been a tremendous set of
accomplishments that
power all sorts of things that we take
for granted
have grandchildren who cannot imagine
that you can't pick up your phone
speak a question and get results back
instantaneously 24x7
so it's powered a lot of um great
accomplishments but i think there are
also some fragilities that work on
things like
robustness universal representations and
uh grounding and abstraction will will
really help
move uh us into to new directions
that's great thank you fantastic answer
and uh looking now to your current role
and and kind of your transition to now
direct
uh three three labs um in the in the
northeast
of north america um how's that
experience been and
and and what excites you about that new
challenge
yeah um you know i think the best word
to describe it is uh it's been
exhilarating i started uh this new role
at the end of january
and the first month i was amazing
fun i traveled to all three of the labs
multiple times i got to know people
project and aspirations
there have been a number and then
coveted right and so there have been a
number
of interesting challenges we all started
working from home
uh in the us there are ongoing civil and
and political challenges natural
disasters from
hurricanes to fires and even to to make
things more interesting
two of those labs moved to new locations
during the pandemic i've never been in
either lab
and so really looking forward to to be
able to getting back to that
so it's been a fun journey one that i'm
really glad i i took on
uh let me say a little bit more about
the labs and and what
excites me about them so the i mean the
three labs started
at different times they're all
relatively new so the new england lab
started 2008 so it's not even
teenager yet the new york lab in in 2012
in the montreal lab only three years ago
and each has a somewhat different
culture and and mix of topical
foci but what all three labs share
is something that i really value and
that we've both
alluded to is that they are highly
interdisciplinary
and that is they they more than many
university departments many industrial
research labs they
bring together people and perspectives
from
computer science from economics from
social sciences
and more recently from biological
sciences to carry out
really exciting world-class
interdisciplinary work that i think
can impact and shape microsoft the
scientific community and
and more broadly uh society and
you know one of the reasons i think this
is so important
to take these broad perspectives is if
you want to solve some of today's
really pressing problems whether they're
technical or societal
it's not enough to just build this
really fancy and cool
algorithm right you need to understand
much more about the socio-technical
environment and which systems
are deployed that co-evolution of things
like work
practices and systems even something
seemingly as simple as web search that
i've done a lot of work on
it's not enough to have a great
algorithm that that takes a query and
matches it to billions of web pages
i mean that's an astounding capability
but it's not
enough to have a successful system or
service and you need to
do things like help people articulate
what they're looking for and we do that
in a variety of ways you need to
help people make sense of the results in
interesting ways
if you're providing the service you need
to deal with a constant
barrage of adversaries and so there's so
much more that goes on
in building and deploying systems at
scale
that um i think the the more
perspectives that we bring to bear on
that the more successful will be and
that's what i'm most excited about i'd
say about the
the three northeast labs is that they
all have this super interesting mix of
uh computational sciences social
sciences economics and uh maybe
biological sciences so
it's really fun to to see people from
those different communities coming
together
that's great what what do you think it
is about the culture at those
labs that makes it so successful that
those types of projects are successful
is it
is it that the people or how they you
know how those projects are
are born or you know is it something
else is it
location to great universities on the
east coast
what what are the key things that make
it successful
yeah i i think it was a lot of it was
very
deliberate to when the new york when the
new england lab was was founded
it was very very deliberately done
to mix computer science economics and
social sciences and so
the lab brought together uh people with
each of those those
different perspectives uh similarly when
the new york
lab started it already had a mix of uh
it started in in large part
from folks who had previously been at
yahoo
and there was really interesting work
there in machine learning computational
social sciences and computational
economics and so
in both cases the seed of the labs was
was people who came from really
different perspectives
and had in the
the labs are sort of small i'd say each
one is 35 to
35-ish 40 people and so you get to know
each other as individuals you develop
i'd say mutual
respect for the perspectives that
different people bring
and um you know i think
have an openness to looking at problems
from multiple different perspectives and
really engaging with others
again as i said you know it's not enough
to have a great algorithm you can have
the world's best learning algorithm it
can be on top of leaderboards but unless
you think
about how something the bigger
environment in which things are going to
be deployed it
it's not very successful and so for me
for me a lot of it was intentional i
think
the people who hi were hired and who
continue to be hired
are people who are open to new ideas
thrive in an environment where there are
people with different perspectives and
so a lot of it involves around getting
to know each other
and really most importantly just having
mutual respect for each other's
perspectives and learning from that and
so i think it's a
really really fun bo all of them are
really really fun places to
be thanks um a question
coming from tom in uh
so what ways what are the ways of
thinking that you have found
most uh successful in terms of you know
figuring out the questions to ask in
your work and also as a
you know director now of labs and and
you have influence over what questions
are asked by researchers in those labs
how do you
approach that um
[Music]
yeah part of my philosophy as a lab
director is you hire really
um talented people who
have some of the you know certainly good
core technical skills but also
approaches to problems
um that will be successful and really
just get the heck out of the way and
and uh support them um but
i guess that's when i um
when i think about um
what makes people successful in
not just uh you know research in
industry but in in research
in general is um
i think as you said asking the the right
questions and so one of the things
i always do when i start a problem and i
encourage
people in the labs to do is
ask yourself uh if i work really hard
and solve this problem
who will care okay and sometimes the
answer might be
my three best friends because it's a
beautiful theoretical problem
in my case it might be my three or four
best friends who are metrics wonks like
i
am and care detailed about measurements
karen you know in the same detail as i
do about measurement and
uh and robustness but more often than
not i
i really care about seeing systems used
much more broadly
both in the you know community and
within
in practice and so i think by being
clear
on you know what your goals are what the
upside is
set yourself up really well for having
that that broader impact
that's great and uh segueing from that
into another question from samiha
what is your vision of ai in 20 years
time
do what are the things that you think we
will
will have been solved or have been
addressed and how will those
matter to society
yeah um well as i said before you know i
think we
we need to develop systems that are
really quite different than than we have
now there
there's amazing capabilities um i
i think we will we'll see systems that
are
certainly less brittle that maybe learn
a little bit more in the ways that
humans learn with smaller sample sizes
that have the ability to generalize
in useful ways have multiple
if you think about people we have
multiple levels of representation
certainly how we process signals and
vision language speech depend on the raw
sensory motor
channel but above that there's a level
of abstraction which brings all of that
together
in a way that allows us to um to
generalize
to learn more efficiently and so on and
i
think we'll we'll see systems have some
of those capabilities of
operating more robustly in the open
world of continuously learning
um of being again not islands of
competency but interacting with other
agents
interacting with people and so i think
we'll you know we'll see
a lot more robustness in an open world
and that's going to allow us to solve
all sorts of
of things from multi-agent systems
to systems that address some of uh you
know the biggest challenges that that we
face as a
as the computer science profession and
really as a society
sorry because many of those challenges
are not things that you can come up with
a nice
neat tidy test collection for and so
again i think it's
um you know thinking about building
things that that interoperate with
with people with other agents um and
doing so in
in a way that is um let's say less
fragile
than many of our current systems
great well thank you very much to um
it's been a fantastic
conversation and we're coming to the end
of our time
um just one fun question from kira
of the three labs which if if if we
weren't working remotely which
which is the one that you would be based
at maybe
you know which is the city you prefer
putting you on the spot you can't ask me
that i can switch
it um
i i have a lot of frequent flyer miles
i'm my
i spend my main office is in um the new
england lab and that's partly because it
was the first lab when i was getting
up and running it's a place where a lot
of
people in the business administration
side of things and
and so on were based and so for me it
was the the place where
i felt i could get the biggest fire hose
of of new
information um but i you know i visited
in one month uh each of the other labs
two times and
before the pandemic hit i had hoped to
spend you know about a week a month
in redmond a week a month in uh you know
new england and then a week
split between new york and montreal and
a week somewhere else
traveling but uh those those plans have
taken a bit of a
left turn but i hope to get back to
doing that to
being in in all the labs and uh you know
learning
from each of them and um i don't i don't
have a favorite they're all amazing in
their own ways
very diplomatic thank you um thank you
once again for
your time and and for being involved um
so thank you
yeah thanks for organizing and to all of
the the students involved have a
a great rest of the the day and day
tomorrow and i'll see you at the the
poster session
shortly i think sean is going to tell us
about how to get there
yeah great transition uh so passing over
to sean now
is going to um lead us into the poster
session
great yeah and thanks so much super for
coming it seems like these
half hour chats fly by in about 30
seconds i wish they could be like 90
minutes
um but thanks for coming that was a
great chat um
so for for everyone who's watching right
now we are about to transition into
uh the interactive poster session so
before we do that
um and this broadcast stream will end in
a few moments but i want to show you
uh just so everyone's on the same page
kind of how to do that
um so everyone knows where everything is
[Music]
um so i assume you're seeing my screen
right now
um so on the main page of hub i mean
there's a there's a whole tab for the
for the poster sessions um which is
going to give you a list of the
the agenda of every every um student's
poster
each of which has its own page um so you
can
you know find yourself you can all you
can search or
find your own name or to find the name
of a person that you'd like to see their
poster
click into it and you'll see maybe a
video if they've submitted a video for
it
the poster itself which you can also
download
by clicking at the bottom of the page
and you can also
jump into a teams meeting there has been
one teams call set up per poster
by clicking on this link here i'm not
going to click it now because it would
be jumping out of here
and so just to clarify again we're
asking i mean basically all students
you're you're welcome to be sitting in
your team's meeting
chatting with people for the whole time
um 1 30 to 3.
if you want to jump around to other
posters we're just asking for
if your last name starts with letter a
through m um be in your your call from
130 to 230
and if your last name starts with the
letters n through z
um try to be in your call from two to
three um so people can jump in and have
conversations with you
um and then just a last note for the the
student attendees
on the agenda after the poster session
we're going to be doing a networking
game
which you can find here that's mingler
bingo we'll explain more about that
when it starts at three o'clock but to
join you can go to the agenda in hub
and again just click this join microsoft
teams online
and we'll have we'll meet you there in
that meeting
okay so that's it um can't wait to see
all of your posters and
talk to you soon
thanks everyone